[Music]
jacob is with us in seattle hi jacob how
are you
i'm doing well dave ken thanks for
taking my call i appreciate it sure
what's up
all right so um me and my wife uh are
currently have no doubt uh looking to
purchase a house in the upcoming
couple years we have a little bit of a
disagreement on how we are going to be
saving the money um i'm
i have a higher risk appetite than she
does i would like to put it into
like a diversified etfs and try to get a
little try to get the money to work for
us for
the upcoming few years before we
purchased and she would like to put it
into a high yield savings account so we
know exactly where we're going to be in
three years
how would you suggest to go about
finding a compromise with that
well i think what you both need to
realize is that this decision is not
going to keep you from buying a house
or cause you to be able to buy a house
so let's do the math for a second i'll
show you what i'm talking about
how much are you talking about saving
um
we would like i would like to purchase a
house that we're going to be in for the
next 30 40 basically our lifetime so
good luck with that but yeah it usually
doesn't work that way but but how much
are you talking about saving in the next
three years
uh about 200 000. okay
and so if you make 10
on this money you're gonna make 20 000
bucks
if you put it in a high yield savings
you're gonna make nothing and you'll
lose twenty thousand bucks
but two hundred thousand is what's going
to cause you to build buy the house
and 220 is not going to cause you to buy
a substantially different house
so the fact that you made a little money
on your money is more of an intellectual
exercise than a factual change in your
situation
okay that makes sense i'm following you
okay and so
uh and the same thing's true with her
let's say you put it into an etf and it
did not make 10 a year
you had a bad three-year run in the
stock market stock market in general was
down you got tagged
you know in the face with this thing
which could happen in a three-year swing
and uh you don't have 200 000 you end up
with 180 000.
so you actually lost money you follow me
still doesn't keep you from buying a
house
so my point is your concern that you're
not making a bunch of money is somewhat
mathematically invalid her concern that
you're going to lose so much that
you're going to not be able to get a
house is also
not really mathematically valid this is
all more about emotion than it is actual
dollars
okay yeah that makes sense i'm following
you yeah so anyway all that to say
how do we solve this
uh
probably at our house
uh we'd probably end up splitting the
baby we'd probably get let me do uh put
a hundred thousand over in investments
and she'd put a hundred thousand over
there and at the end we would see who
won the bet
so you would say put it do a 50 50 down
the middle yeah yeah i don't think
there's anything wrong with that at all
because but again
before you do this both of you need to
really own the fact that this is not
going to cause you to buy a house or not
buy a house
it's just more of an argument over how
we park the money
so i got to weigh in here
you know look i i think you do exactly
what dave just laid out walk her through
that
both sides of the coin then i would see
how she's reacting to that and if her
safety
gland is still flaring
what's the other alternative that's the
other alternative yeah you don't lose on
that one
because if you win if you put it all in
there and you go down 30 grand i told
you that's going to cost you 30 years
yeah of remembering that yeah
that's the truth and maybe some jewelry
it costs you a thousand dollars a year
in memory that's my remember back in on
23 when you didn't do what i should do
they have memories oh oh they are
members elephants have nothing on women
yeah this is true they remember yeah
ever
especially when they're right
that's even more devastating which again
if you want just most of the time
that's what you need to come to that
conclusion as well so this is not even a
mathematical question find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her
and he will have no lack of gain so at
our house we probably today we would
split the baby 20 years ago when we were
still a little fresher
the the nerves were still a little more
raw after going broke yeah we probably
would have parked it yeah in a high
yield savings and we're not taking any
risk because sharon
was so terrorized yes emotionally by
what we went through
that it took a decade for her to go and
we had to have a big old pile of money
where she could go oh if you screw that
up over there it ain't gonna kill you
and she's still one of the most frugal
people i know oh my god the woman will
pick up an old used golf ball right like
no one i have ever seen we have a
collection of old used golfers
she's going to get bit by a snake
getting getting a golf ball that's worth
50 cents because it's already been hit
by the mower yeah it's unbelievable the
woman is
yeah yeah she no frugal frugal don't
even touch it yeah all right and and
that's a compliment
to compliment my darling